[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez nous sommes
[Musique]
alors nous sommes le ânesse de son souci
donc les rassurer les sans soucis forexi
a tonné dans l'ouest de l'île entre est
un juste au dessus de la ville de
saint-paul le net de son souci est
particulier parce que c'est un oeil ce
qui est découpée en lanières en bande c
suite en fait au partage des les portes
de la compagnie des indes succession est
entêté
au niveau des parcelles des polos et cns
qui va depuis le village sans souci et
qui débute hiroshima la cressonnière et
qui va jusqu'à la ligne de magna
l'honneur
donc on est un 9 104 mètres d'altitude
donc sonné en va bien dans le type de
forêt pourrait y ait pas de couleurs
débat ici
donc température moyenne ici on va dire
ça peut aller très à 23 degrés quand ça
dépend et
donc on va dire
particularité du site c'est la présence
d'espèces rares espaces qui sont classés
sur mes lacets
mon travail si con c'est ce qu'on essaie
à l'autre quel chemin et
d'entretien et puis avec modestie et des
plantations segmentation des bandits
milk et - dias arrêté
en février beaucoup beaucoup de
l'entretien parle fascine
[Musique]
sur le la de son souci on va rencontrer
essentiellement comme type de trolls les
oiseaux forestiers endémiques de la
réunion à savoir le
le spectacle le papangue
l'oiseau lunette vers le 3e blanc et
puis
le mercredi
alors comme floch caratéristiques ici
bon c'est assez
on va bien c'est assez spécial
comme espace car ici on va comme on l'a
vu tout au long du sentier on a retrouvé
du bois d'artnet ans du bois joli coeur
du bois de boulettes et comme espèce on
va dire un peu plus rare c'est le bois
jaune de woippy ans donc ça dépend en
fait
thaçi dont il s'est entouré de bois de
couleur n'est pas une forêt semi sèche
donc là vous présente une espèce qu'il y
ait donc
mimiques
de la réunion saint conwoïon c'est le
bois d'artnet donc lui ses défunts qui
sont simples la faille est simple donc
elle n'est pas composée de plusieurs
petites feuilles
le bord de la feuille c'est légèrement
donc comblé et c'est une des
caractéristiques de l'espace et quand on
va tracer les feuilles ça va dégager une
odeur de pomme de reinette doux surnom
boidin
[Musique]
en anjou représente une autre espace
le changer corse a la particularité
c'est toujours des feuilles simple
d'accord donc contrairement à ce qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure la marge des feuilles
le bord édenté d'accord changer corse
pourquoi
en fait quand il va grandir on va avoir
les camps ce qui s'explique qui va
s'échapper en fait sur donc à fleurier
ati forme ici son latin informix à dire
que les feuilles sont en forme la fin
ressemble étrangement à la fin de l'été
c'est l'effet skier donc indigènes de la
veille
[Musique]
son bien être est ce parce intéressante
aussi qu'on s'empare dans ce type de
milieu c'est le café marron de son nom
parce que dans son cri ressemble
étrangement à celui des cas ces
caractéristiques du café marron monde
entier feuilles sont opposés donc face à
face et surtout lorsqu'on fait on va
bien regarder au niveau de la surface de
la feuille on va avoir comme des petits
boutons des points donc qu'ils sont à
l'intersection la viande principales et
secondaires qu'on appelle les dom à 6
après c'est génétique manquera pas là
l'espèce mois donc très peu d'espèces
mais cette caractéristique donc de si
longs qu'à la réunion
voilà donc ces espaces qui y est on va
dire à l'époque on
avec le café marron on faisait tories
fier ce qu'a fait l'équipe lui avait en
fait
le cocon peinture
[Musique]